[Music]  the popular game Diablo 3 was just  released for the PlayStation 3 and Xbox  360 and I've been playing it right at  home to sort of test drive it sure now I  have to say the graphics and the  gameplay are great but the character  voices and the dialogue in the game  really don't seem to suit the dark and  violent tone of that world in my opinion  I was very very disappointed I'll show  you some check it out these guys outbid  me at the antique show this roaring fire  let's make s'mores I'll be the graham  crackers you be the marshmallow in  chocolate  running through the woods okay be cool  no somersaults I can't help it I think I  love a microbrew maybe an IPA nothing  too hoppy  I'll have a mango margarita  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]